what we've got here is the YikeBike
this is a compact folding electric bike
so grant tell me about this bike and why
does it look so bizarre okay so we've
tried to make it and it is the smallest
lightest electric folding bike in the
world and the reason it looks so weird
is rather than just take a normal bike
and crunch it up we decided to you know
relook at the bike design and try and
make it as small and light as possible
okay um now the motor and the battery
and everything are inside this kind of
front wheel right yes so there's a tiny
little motor that's got more power than
Lance Armstrong it's about one pound and
the battery and everything's inside the
front wheel so you can use that space to
fold up the back wheel every inch of
space is used okay
how fast can you go and how far can you
go on the charge that's about 40 miles
40 miles per hour you can go and the
range is about six miles with this
version all they'll be extended battery
backs to double or prefer okay so 14
miles an hour and six miles you'd be
able to be good for most commutes how
much does it cost
that's about 3,500 okay so $3,500 and
I'm going to be riding this weird thing
that kind of just seat the handlebars
are behind me do you think people are
really going to go for this absolutely
it's a really it's a really clean green
way to get around town it means you can
take it on the bus on the fray and you
never leave it outside and never get
stolen it's a bargain
okay I'll believe it when I see it can
you show me how to ride it
sure no worries
all right
you